Welcome home, Master and Ma'am!
And Merry Christmas!
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hello!
Merry Christmas.
Minky Christmas.
Merry Minky.
Minky, Minky, Minky.
Mintle Christmas.
Merry Goody.
Hello!
Gosh, my voice.
I'm so sorry.
Hi!
I like how this intro is like a mix of...
4, like Metal Gear Solid 4 and then Metal Gear Solid 1.
Because it's like the Metal Gear Solid 1...
What's the word?
Title screen.
Minky Christmas!
Looking forward to cracking up to...
I'm really looking forward to cracking up.
It's been a while since I really cracked up.
I love that clip so much.
Commando Reindeer.
The way she reigns as my deer.
Merry Christmas.
Merry... What?
P-Box!
Thanks for 8 months!
And Prick!
Thanks for 8 months.
Thank you guys.
Big Mac!
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
Thank you.
I crack up every stream.
Guilemon, thank you for the... Thanks not only for the...
The keys, but also for the keys in chat.
I saw some lucky wisps get Ace Combat 7.
Lucky, lucky.
Merry Goody, Mintle.
Merry Goody!
I'm looking forward to cracking up.
Santa Paul, thank you so much for the pink.
Thank you for the 50 gifts.
Sorry, I didn't tell you...
Hi everybody at once.
Sorry, I didn't tell you what my wish was yesterday and all.
Thank you for the pink.
Merry Christmas, Mintle.
Merry Christmas, Nathan.
Say Merry Christmas.
Merry Christmas.
144.8 hours later, Holocure is 100%.
What?
100%ed?
How many?
Hold on.
Wait, 100%ed in-game or...
Or Steam?
Wait, what am I at?
What?
Mickey, Mickey, Mickey.
Sorry, you can't hear it.
The music is so loud, but I can hear it a little bit.
Thanks, Ducky!
I'm thankful and proud of you.
Yikes.
I'm ready to hear your wish.
Happy Holidays, Mintle.
You are the father.
No!
I'm not.
My wife, Bon, is unfortunately trapped away from home in a customer-facing job all night tonight.
Lend her some big fests of energy to help get through her shift.
A shift on Christmas?
That's so sad.
No!
And here is all my energy!
Blah!
Except unfortunately.
Guys, I don't have so much energy today.
I don't even have so much energy myself today.
I am so...
My tummy hurt real.
I'm a little bit out of it today.
But, that's okay.
Merry Christmas, Mintle.
Are you in Japan right now?
I'm not in Japan.
Not yet.
Not yet, not yet.
Yeah, I'm real tummy hurt hours today.
I took some medicine, but it didn't do anything.
So, I'm a little...
I'm like a little...
If I feel a little winded, a little low energy, that's it.
Today, I really didn't do much of anything.
I cleaned a little bit.
I watched a show that...
That a friend recommended called Severance.
Have you guys ever heard of it before?
It's pretty interesting.
I'm on episode...
6.
Good ass show.
My tummy also hurts.
It's the baby.
Shut up.
The show is intense.
I've not heard of it.
So, basically...
It's about...
Yeah, there's a season 2 coming out pretty soon.
Hold on, I'm turning down the music a little bit.
Basically, it's about...
Like a company.
And then, at the company...
They have like this level...
The basement floor is like...
The Severance people.
I'm sending this now, because I've got to do Christmas dinner.
Have fun.
Bye bye!
And it's like...
It's basically real life workplace.
No, it's...
It's like...
It's work-life balance to the extreme.
Sorry, I'm so like foggy brain today.
It's like work-life balance to the extreme.
So basically, they implant this chip in your head...
That when you go to the basement of the building...
You have like this separate...
Person.
That...
Is your work self.
You have your work self, and then when you leave...
You become your normal self.
And...
No way, seriously?
I've never heard that before.
No, no, it's like a...
It's like an actual thing.
Yeah, it is like a split personality thing.
It is like a split personality thing.
And the people in the workplace know nothing...
Basically, they call them innies and outies.
Like the belly button.
And like...
The innies, the workplace people are like...
Oh yeah, I don't know anything about my outie.
I don't know what they do.
I don't know if I have a family.
I don't know anything, because...
Basically, they are supposed to be there to only focus on the job.
And then, once you leave, you can...
Just, you know, be like...
Oh, I don't have to think about anything from work.
I can just...
Enjoy my weekend or whatever.
The rest of my day.
So...
It is intriguing.
And then there is like all like the...
It's like the moral dilemma.
Like, oh my god, your workplace person...
When you leave...
Like...
They basically fall asleep.
And then, when you go back to work, they never get a break, you know?
So...
It's like, oh, it's kind of interesting.
The folks in work know nothing about their lives out of work.
And the folks outside of work have no idea what they are working on.
Exactly!
That's basically...
That's basically it.
Like, they don't know anything about...
Vice versa.
So...
Oh, Tom!
I also meant to say thank you for the...
For the model gift.
I saw it.
Thank you.
I meant to reply.
I forgot.
I'm sorry.
Arion!
Thank you for the hot kiss!
Thank you so much!
Merry Christmas!
You got it.
Yeah, I did!
Sorry, I've been super behind on emails.
So...
I've been super behind on a lot of stuff.
But over when I'm in Japan, I plan on catching up on stuff too.
One's a slave while the other gets to do regular stuff.
Yeah, kind of.
Just wrapped up with our festivities.
I'm ready to wind down here.
Merry Christmas, Mingto and Wis.
Merry Christmas!
Thank you, Arthur!
Yeah, thank you guys for being here.
If you're, you know...
Probably, like...
If you're with family or if you're...
If you're...
Or if you're...
What's the word?
You know, just doing Christmas stuff.
Thanks for hanging out still.
I appreciate it.
Like I said, I really didn't do anything except watch that show.
And kind of just...
I was just like...
I was dying.
Well, I'm already dead.
But, you know, tummy hurt on the couch.
I must have possessed someone that ate something bad.
Don't eat...
Don't eat bad things and have me possess you, okay?
My tummy hurt too.
My parents got my boyfriend and me socks that say...
His support, her carry.
And then asked what game it was from.
What?
What game is it from?
What did you say?
Must have been me, my bad.
No, no!
No, it was me, Mac and Cheese and Lactose Intolerance.
No!
Mary Chrysler.
Mary Chrysler!
What was the game?
You could have said something like really...
Like...
You could have been like, oh, it's from...
I don't know why, this is the first thing that pops into my...
You could have been like, oh, it's from Do You Like Horny Bunnies?
Don't say Orc Massage.
Stop.
Merry Mintmas!
Why is that the first game on your mind?
I don't know, I was just trying to think of a silly...
Like a...
You know, like a game with a silly title.
Today was my first attempt at homemade pineapple pizza with red onions, ground beef and black olives.
You lost me at the olives.
I'm sorry, Ghost of Mint.
But yeah, anyway, today we're playing Merry Gear Solid.
I played the first one.
A bit ago.
Oh, I wanted to ask.
What did you guys get for...
From Santa?
Did you guys get any presents you liked?
Did you guys get anything?
Thanks for the five gifts!
Five gifts, so sorry.
Thank you for the superchat, I appreciate it.
A blanket?
Sounds nice.
A camera?
Oh, a camera.
Camera.
Pants?
Pants.
New monitor!
New pajamas.
I got MGS collection for Switch, let's go!
Depression, oh.
New iPad!
Switch 2?
Oh my gosh, your dad works at Nintendo?
AirPods Pro, let's go!
Merry Christmas!
Mint-chan, you look good in red.
Thank you!
Even though it's mint green.
I'm glad it suits me.
A lemon juicer.
Say you're an adult without saying you're an adult.
I got a lemon juicer and I'm excited about it!
I got a Cali pop-up parade figure.
Nice!
Abbott, thank you so much for the 10 gifts!
I unironically got a sweater.
What's wrong with that?
A cute watch.
Nice.
I'm glad you guys got lots of good stuff it seems.
Except the depression, maybe.
I hope you guys can return that to the store.
I hope they gave you a receipt with it.
Don't feel bad if you return it.
Mariano!
Thank you for the birthday gift!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you.
Did I get something?
No?
Oh.
I have the gift of hanging out with you all.
The gift of us being together.
I found the pickle in the Christmas tree.
I was rewarded with a $40 gift card.
What am I taking you...
Wait!
Outback?
That's the place with the blooming onion, isn't it?
I want to eat that!
Actually, I've been to Outback before, but only a long, long time ago.
But I went somewhat recently.
But it was in Japan of all places.
Last time I was in Japan...
Me and Pia and a couple of other people...
We went out to dinner and we went to Outback.
After the Tokyo game show.
And I tried the blooming onion for the first time.
Merry Christmas, Minto!
Thanks!
Next time!
Thank you for the pink!
You got the gift of hanging out with us and also $50.
Let's go!
I have splurged a little bit.
So I basically bought...
You know, I splurged on computer parts and I got myself a new keyboard.
I've splurged a little bit, probably.
A little too much, maybe.
I did get myself stuff.
It's all stuff that's coming later, though.
I won't have it until I get back.
And I bought some, like...
I bought a dress from one of my favorite Japanese brands.
Which I wanted for my trip, but it's not coming in time.
So I'm kind of sad.
But it's okay.
Do you have somewhere the delivery will be safe?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, my maid cafe has a safe place to store stuff.
So it'll all be good.
Yeah.
Okay, so you didn't get nothing.
Well, I mean, it's me.
I bought the stuff myself.
I bought it.
I gotta replace my VR headset.
Oh no, did it break?
Merry Minkymas!
Is it a cute dress?
I think it's cute.
Can we see the dress?
No.
Then I can't wear it out.
It's kind of unique.
It's kind of a unique dress.
Sorry.
But I did get also a scarf with the dress.
And it's like a little scarf that is a...
It's a bunny, you know?
It's got like a...
When you wrap it around, it looks like a bunny.
So it's pretty cute, I think.
Is it from Uniqlo?
No!
Wait, does Uniqlo have stuff like that?
Sounds cute.
It is pretty cute.
Windows is removing Windows Mixed Reality Support, so it's going to break?
What?
Yeah, yeah, kind of like a Pekora's scarf.
Yeah, actually.
Online Japanese store?
Yeah, it is like a Pekora's scarf.
Yeah, wait.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Usada Pekora.
Yes!
Actually, it's so much like that.
That's so silly.
Wow, ice cream!
Merry Christmas, my Kamiyoshi!
Thank you for the hakusupa.
Thank you!
Thank you.
Santa Costa.
I thought of something crazy you could do since you're a ghost.
What if you possessed the bodies of...
Of death row inmates and made their last meal request for them.
That's so morbid.
It's Christmas.
What are you thinking about?
Merry... Merry Krimmy from Happy Holidays and New Years.
Thanks, Patch!
Alright guys, enough yappin'.
Enough yappin'.
I think this game is pretty much longer from the previous Merry Gear Solid we did.
This is actually a fan game.
So, you know.
Meant to quote a famous coffee commercial.
You are my present this year.
Agent, is that... I think I literally referenced that yesterday.
Or rather, I mentioned it yesterday.
Is that the... How do you say that coffee brand?
Is it Folgers or Folger?
Fol... Folgers in your cup.
Folgers cup.
Cough.
Folgers.
You guys know that one?
The creepy, like, brother and sister one?
Folgers.
Like a GIF.
Oh, okay, okay.
Folgers.
The what?
So it's like...
I know it very well.
What, do you watch it every year as like a tradition?
Gotta ask before I have to wait another year.
Can I get a Christmas Carol ghost quote?
Maybe... Come in and know me better, bro.
Huh?
What?
What is a Christmas Carol ghost quote?
Someone had too much eggnog.
Okay, I'm channeling ghosts of Christmas future.
I'm the ghost of Christmas future.
And... get in the coffin.
Dead.
That's it.
There's a bunch of fanfics.
I could've... I could've... I could've gone another day.
I could've... I could've been dead another day not knowing that.
Thank you.
Okay.
Merry Gear Solid 2.
Ghosts of Christmas past.
Oh, maybe I should've channeled the ghosts of Christmas past.
You... young version of me.
Don't... eat that dirt.
You'll get ringworm.
A good lesson for all of us.
Okay then.
Now I want Oreo.
Thinking of like those ice creams with the gummy worms in it.
Oreo.
So this is a fan game.
I played the first one.
Now we're playing the second one.
And look at that.
It's so much like...
It's so... It's... It's very...
It feels... It feels...
Really polished, that's the word.
Spoofy, yeah!
And I guess we're gonna be old...
San... Snake... Santa...
San... I don't know.
Sans!
We're gonna be old Sans!
New game!
Control.
Are you sure?
Yes.
Naughty.
Album introduction
Perfect intro music.
Thank you Takeso Thank you.
So appreciative to spend Christmas with you this year in the west.
Yeah!
Me too.
Are these children slaves?
Minky, minky, minky, minky...
It's just my imagination.
Wow, these children are talking!
Based on Metal Gear Solid by Hideo Kojima.
Hopefully I don't block so much.
If I do, I can put my arms down, but...
I don't want to do that.
It's unnatural.
Holy loud!
I like how it's a mix of so many things.
It's Snake?
It's such a mix of all the different Metal Gear games.
Sore throat Otacon.
LOL
Otacon's eyes be like...
Big Beep, Big Beep, Big Beep.
SOC System?
LOL
LOL LOL That's me!
That's me!
How they're saving is great.
Oh my god!
Oh no!
LOL
Metal Gear.
The ghosts!
The president's at the mall?
What's wrong with my old codename?
Are these not already codenames?
The Ha-Hu-Hu-Hu.
Cold Snake?
Got it.
LOL Thanks!
Oh my gosh.
Wow!
Look how fancy this is now!
Oh my god!
Look at the little Cold Snake!
That's today.
I see.
Wait.
Those are the stairs I think.
No, go back to sleep kid.
It's ok.
This kid's voice.
I feel asleep.
How do I sneak?
We're fine.
Ok, good to know it's over.
Is this a door?
No, I can't go there.
I feel asleep.
Oh wait, I see it down there.
Shift, wall hug, control, action.
Just from the intro alone you can tell the big differences between Merry Gear 1 and 2.
What!?
I didn't even do anything!
I was reading in Super Chat!
Oh my god!
I wasn't doing anything!
I didn't even move!
Oh my god.
Sorry guys, my stomach is like...
Holy moly.
Holy night.
I'm gonna run for it.
Oh ok, nevermind.
He just...I thought it was because he heard me.
Ok.
Oh my goodness!
It's icy.
I can't see.
Oh ok.
We're fine.
Otacon, what do I do about this child?
To do that, hug a wall with the shift key and then press the control key to make a noise.
Any nearby guards will come investigate the source of the noise.
You can use this to open up a sneaking path.
So I press control while hugging a wall to knock on it.
Got it.
Say, Otacon.
Knock knock.
What was that noise?
You're supposed to say who's there.
It's just my imagination.
Another thing I've been watching.
So there's this one guy...
Oh my gosh, I can't remember his username right now.
It's a Japanese...or rather...I think it's a Japanese guy.
He plays so much Metal Gear Solid 3.
Like an insane amount.
Like, he is so...
His methods are like so crazy.
And so I was watching him play today.
Big Saru.
I'm pretty sure that's him.
Monkey Mask videos.
Yes!
I love his videos so much.
Nicholas, welcome to bamboo ship.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, he's so crazy.
I love watching his stuff.
He's actually like...
It's so fun because it's not like a speedrun.
He just does it because he's just like...
Craziness, you know?
Like it's just so funny.
Let's see.
If I knock...Oh, I can't get in here.
I was gonna knock...Oh wait, I can.
So, shift...
Do you think he'll see me?
Stupid kid.
Dumbass kid.
Stupid.
Oh god, you guys.
I'm so sorry.
I'm gonna take some stomach medicine right now.
I took some medicine earlier, but...
Maybe I need...
Found the intruder.
Oh my god.
Heckin' kid, man.
Heckin' kids.
Oh gosh.
The music.
Oh my gosh, we have like an actual...
Radar now.
Oh my gosh, look at it.
Hold on.
Sorry, this is the worst my stomach has been in a bit.
Can I open this?
Open, please.
Open!
I have to use my teeth.
Microplastics.
Yeah, I'm cosplaying Johnny.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
Hello?
The Joliton Radar.
Joliton?
Joliton.
Being dead and still dealing with stomach aches sounds awful, Minto.
Not gonna lie.
That's what I told you.
Being a ghost, being dead is overrated.
Okay.
Yeah.
No.
What a nerd.
Nerd.
Radar and multiple soundtracks.
It is a big leap.
Alright, so what do these kids do?
Can I walk?
Oh, oops.
I thought he was...
I thought he was gonna walk.
Why didn't he move?
Gotcha.
This kid is annoying.
Okay.
For the camera.
Otacon, what do I do?
Oh.
I just knew that.
Wow.
So just this.
Gotcha.
Hold up, Snake.
Someone's conversation is being carried through the ventilation shaft.
Yes, sir.
Sharp voice and chilly voice.
What?
I'm sorry, this is a mall with 20 floors?
You can tell this was made long ago.
You can tell this was made long ago because they had enough confidence to think that malls would be so big.
It's a super mall for real.
Let's see.
Okay, we gotta get to that elevator there.
It's got this little punk looking...
Oh, there's a guy right there.
I thought he was...
I'm here.
What?
Okay.
I guess I'll go this way then.
Oh, this is a way through.
That's neat.
Gosh.
Oh my God.
Hello?
Scary.
I am?
Okay, I'll go that way then.
Spirit Halloween.
Spirit...what was it?
Spirit Christmas.
A new one.
Am I in the storage room?
There's a kid in here.
Why can't I kill the kids?
I mean, take them out.
Oh my God.
I'm running for it.
Oh, this is a bathroom.
This is not where I thought I needed to be.
It's right there.
Oopsie.
Oh my gosh.
The other kid came in.
Spooked me.
I'm gonna wake him up with my footsteps.
Oh,
okay.
I'm like moonwalking.
Spirit Halloween has a market cap of 1.86 billion dollars and is owned by Spencers.
Yes, that's Spencers.
I got a Dina mask.
Shmovin'?
Does Mito mean convert them to ghosts?
Nah.
I want you to know that Ferdom has been around for a long time.
Huh?
Ferdom?
Yeah, you know, furries.
It's a fandom that revolves around anthropomorphic animals.
Anime.
It's always anime with you, isn't it, Avacon?
I'm a mercenary.
I don't have time for any nerd hobbies.
Now tell me how I can use this thing.
Well, for a start, it's frighteningly realistic.
Has it got a red light up nose?
Nope.
Darn.
So it's no good as a flashlight either.
Let me put this thing on.
Maybe it'll give me some ideas.
Oh wait, I forgot...
I forgot to put on my eyepatch.
Sorry.
Oh, it's a deer mask!
Oh really?
What?
OK OK Oh no, that kid's waking up.
Oh no!
Wait, how do I put it on?
How do I put it on?
A Z?
A deer mask.
It allows the user to be undetectable when standing while hugging a wall.
Oh my god, look at that!
I'm moonwalking?
Uh, kid?
Are you gonna do anything?
He's camping me.
Hello?
Just a deer.
Um, let's see.
If I...
Oh, uh, shoot.
OK This might be good.
Alright.
OK
He's not gonna come by me, is he?
Oh my god, don't touch me.
Oh my god.
Uh, oh, shoot.
Uh...
Stinkin' kid.
Stinkin' kid!
OK, uh, what is it?
Z?
Deer mask, OK.
Um, let's see.
How do I wanna get away from this kid?
I think I'm just gonna have to run for it.
Hi!
OK, there we go.
Can he see me here?
Can't tell.
Oh, I'm like, right in his cone though.
Run!
I'm just a deer.
Where am I?
I think I'm blocked by those boxes there.
Yeah, yeah.
Thanks, Ehi!
Oh, I'm sorry, I don't think you got the hot dog, Gachou.
I don't think you got it.
OK, I think we're blocked by the boxes.
We need to go down.
Hmm...
He's looking, he's looking.
Look over to the left.
Oh, stinking other kid.
Uh oh, I think I'm trapped.
No, I'm not.
I'm good.
Oops.
They heard nothing.
Anyway...
Outer saving.
What the heck is this?
Did I go to the wrong place?
Wow, they took every measure.
Do I sound like a girl to you?
He sounds like Liquid too.
The gas.
That makes sense.
I thought he was going to be like, call me Frosty.
Such a lust for Christmas cheer.
He didn't hear it.
Of what?
No.
Wow, thanks Otacon.
This is so silly.
No.
Okay.
I love the deer.
Oh my god, stop calling me.
The what?
Okay, is that a good thing or...
The Muzak.
Oh my god.
One of them is still asleep, this little slacker.
Slacking kid.
Oh, what's that?
I want whatever that is.
Oh my god, that scared the hell out of me.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, that scared me.
Genuine scream.
Oh my god.
Let's...
Yeah, but I want it.
What?
He doesn't believe in me.
Thanks for the Aqua Super!
Thank you!
Merry Christmas, boss.
Merry Christmas!
I think I can get it.
Let's see, how would I...
Can you crawl?
You cannot.
Let's see, maybe if I...
I don't know how to...
Snap his neck.
It's a child!
If I knock, I'm still trying to figure out how I sneak past him.
Put socks over your boots.
Because as soon as I move, he's gonna hear it, you know?
I wish I could CQC the kids.
Maybe Otacon's got a point.
We'll come back.
We're not gonna be getting Elf rank in this, I'm afraid.
I
have a laser vision!
I got stuck on the wall, you little brat!
You're getting cold.
You're getting cold for Christmas.
Nothing, nothing good in your stocking.
I have to wait.
OK.
Alright, let's see.
Is this... Oh, this is the ice!
Guess who's getting terrible rank.
It's me!
It's Amito!
Oh my god.
Once...
OK.
Where am I?
Why is this mall so confusing?
How do I... I think I might have to go all the way around though.
This is how I feel like when you're a kid and you go to the mall.
This is how I feel like probably a kid's interpretation of the mall is, you know?
Where they're just like... Oh, it's just so genuinely confusing.
Confusing.
Oh shit.
OK, I think we're good actually.
I can trick the children.
Wait, how do I get through?
Oh, I think I messed up.
Wait, where's the... How do I get over there?
Did I go the wrong way?
Was there even anything over there?
Oops.
I'm sliding?
I see... OK.
I think I got so distracted by...
Here we go.
There's this.
Curious what's in here.
Why does it look so ominous?
Raiden?
Oh, police?
Are there bosses in this game?
And there he goes.
Thank you for the 50 gifts.
Thank you.
Cold.
Oh, he keeps drinking.
I don't like that.
These sound effects.
Oh my god.
Cheer.
Otherwise the milk would spoil.
Yeah.
Especially if you're lactose intolerant.
But I've got no time to dwell in the past.
Snake, today is your best buy date.
And let me make it milky clear...
that you shall be bested by this battle's end.
Oh my god!
How do I fight you?
Uh...
How am I supposed to fight?
No he's not!
He's literally right there!
Um... I have nothing to attack him with.
Is there like a... a thermostat or something I can turn up?
Is there like anything that I can change the...
Otacon, what do I do?
Otacon, the enemy.
His blood is white.
The last time I've seen that was...
That's not white blood Snake, that's milk.
Milk?
What?
I don't even have any weapons.
I have... I can't even use my hands.
Control does nothing.
What am I supposed to do?
The music is so good.
Attack!
Ouch.
Will my... wait, Z?
Will my deer do anything?
Oops.
I got the shit on him!
Throw a... wait.
What do you mean?
I literally...
I have no actions though.
So I'm not sure what to do.
Just tolerate it.
Drink him.
How do I do that though?
Keep getting hit?
Let's try it.
Just gonna stand right here.
Look Snake, we've got to hurry before this situation gets real sour.
I'm actually so confused.
He's got that real Stormtrooper angle.
Sir, I'm right here.
Is there... I didn't see like a thermostat or anything to make it hot in here or anything.
You can't get past the boxes.
I'm just kind of like...
I feel like I'm just stuck.
I'm not taking damage, no.
Maybe?
Hold on.
How?
Yes!
What?
Are you serious?
Wait, actually?
But it's Christmas!
No way.
Wait.
Clock.
Icon.
Date and time.
Wait.
Set time automatically turn off.
Set the date and time manually.
I'm gonna change it to... Oh my gosh, I'm gonna change it to...
I'm gonna change it to December 25th, 2025!
Oh my God, it worked!
It worked!
This is so funny.
My chat disconnected.
Oh no!
My father.
My father was one of the three wise men.
Are you guys still here?
My internet.
He was well on his way to inherit the title of Father Christmas.
When in a freak accident at San Geronimo.
His body literally burned itself up.
That special blue fox sneaking suit.
You must be Python's kid.
Am I still streaming?
I can't tell at all.
What the hell is going on?
What's happening?
Why am I frozen?
What is going on?
What's happening?
I'm still streaming.
Ok, hold on.
Why am I frozen?
Help me!
What?
I'm not even paying attention.
I'm sorry Milkman.
I changed the date back, yeah.
It ruined everything on my computer.
Oh my goodness.
Merry Gear?
Is this help?
This is so silly.
Frosty?
I'm still here by the way.
I'm just here.
Frosty?
What?
So that's why the ghosts are demanding Nick's brain.
We had planned to obtain Saint Nick's brain and extract the final passcode.
Giving us access to the Merry Gear.
But how would this help you deliver your milk?
Snake, you aren't thinking outside of the box.
Or rather, perhaps that is exactly what you are doing.
What do you mean?
Think, Snake.
If the Merry Gear is only capable of launching gift boxes...
Put the milk in a gift box.
Yes!
The greatest gift of all!
I don't think anybody wants boxed milk.
Snake, it was only my dream to make the world a happier place through milk.
It seems that your dreams have expired.
And I along with them.
But don't cry.
I'll be back again someday.
I guess there's no use crying over spilled milk.
The present!
Zeshu, happy birthday!
Oh,
the music spooked me.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Zeshu!
Happy birthday!
Alright, we got our first boss.
At what cost?
Truly.
Oh wait, hold on.
My settings are all messed up now.
That's one down, Snake.
Just two more to go.
If I remember correctly, one of the ghosts is on the first floor.
Continue making your way down there.
That's where we've been trying to go.
Cold Snake needs some sunglasses after that finishing phrase.
Okay,
there we go.
Alrighty.
I'm gonna put my deer mask back on.
Very next to...
If I...
Will they come all the way up here?
Oh, I think I did need to...
distract them like that.
This little brat!
Ah, screw you!
You were supposed to look awesome!
I see Psycho Mintus messing up your setup.
At least we got a Portable Ops reference in the game.
The second kid!
Oh, I
messed up.
I messed up.
Honestly, this game is dope.
It's such an improvement.
Like, it's kind of insane.
How much they have changed and...
Okay, now while they are up here...
Wait!
I messed up again.
Why do you go all the way up there?
I hate this kid!
Let me murder!
Let me murder, please!
I got you!
Thank you for the 50 Gems!
Thank you so much!
Why does he go all the way up?
Okay, I think I know what I'm going to do instead.
I'm going to go here instead.
Stupid kids.
Stupid ass kids.
You should be asleep.
Naomi is hunting supplies!
I hear Ocelot.
Exotic survival cuisine.
Six buffets.
More than enough to fuel anything that moves.
Six buffets?
More than enough to refuel anything that moves?
The revolving omelette.
What is this?
Exotic survival cuisine.
Six buffets.
More than enough to fuel anything that moves.
Oh fill, not fuel.
My bad.
Oh my gosh, still though.
That is so... omelette.
Oh my goodness, this is so good.
Outer.
Is this the first floor?
Are we here?
These kids won't see me, right?
Just kidding.
Oh, just kidding.
Galloway Gardens?
I just realized the names.
Merry Christmas!
This Eden place is taken strays?
Oh my gosh, Bankuro!
The cookie recipe you blessed a few days ago won first at the Christmas party.
I'm entering them as Minto blessed cookies in my recipe book.
Not published.
Oh my gosh!
I hope you got something good for it.
Wait, where am I?
What is going on?
Is that kid throwing up?
What's happening?
Is he okay?
Am I making a break for it?
Let's see.
Nothing here.
I know we have to distract this guy.
Just figuring out how I want to do it.
Hey, I'm pressing shift.
Why am I not hugging the wall?
And there's a security camera.
This is like it's own thing.
Oh, I see.
Oh, because I can hide behind it.
So maybe if I like...
Wait.
I think
I'll have enough time to...
Okay, hold on.
You think he'll...
Oh, you stinking kid!
What the hell?
Why didn't you go around the tree?
I hate kids.
I have to do this all over again.
I need this guy to go puke his brains out again.
Whatever he's doing over here.
How do I distract him?
I
could do that.
Dummy kid.
Stupid kid.
Oh, now we have another dummy kid.
How does this game compare with Ghost Babble gameplay wise?
I don't know.
It's hard to say.
Okay.
Do not mind the entire deer-headed mountain.
Deer-headed mountain onto the side of the Christmas tree.
Yeah, don't worry about it.
Don't even think about it.
It's fine.
Okay, hold on.
Wait.
This might be risky.
But we gotta take risks.
Why are there so many kids?
Oh.
Intruder to the left.
Intruder to the right.
That's how I feel about this scene.
Gonna wait.
Easy.
Everyone loves a nice rack.
No need to question it.
True.
Okay.
Check the storage room.
What's up here?
Zone of the Fenders?
This is too much.
How are the puns so tough?
Sorry, hold on.
I'm adjusting my computer.
There we go.
What's the other one?
Not a cotton.
I'm surrounded.
Jeez, do you do that every time I get caught?
Yeah.
How'd you manage to escape alive?
Turns out these kids are mannequins.
Mannequins?
Oh, that's right.
You're in a children's clothing store.
Still, you'll want to be extra careful there.
That's the perfect place to set up an ambush.
That's what they said that there was gonna be.
If only your radar wasn't jammed, you'd be able to avoid the real guards.
Maybe you should try to do something about that and come back later.
What's the storage closet?
I said I wanted to go.
Wait, where's the storage closet though?
Is it here?
Over here?
Really giving that full liminal space experience that lots of models have nowadays.
Oh my god.
Am I going the right way?
It wasn't me.
Otacon, there's a sleeping kid in here with a note taped to his back.
What's it say?
Now I have a polar gun.
Ho, ho, ho.
Looks like this elevator is no good either.
Now this is an elevator?
Interesting.
Okay, so now we have to go all the way back to the revolver amulet.
That's a Die Hard reference!
Oops.
I only watched Die Hard once.
So they turn to the right.
Intruder to the right!
Nothing?
Go back to your position, kid.
I'm not sure what that means.
Stupid kid.
God.
Stupid ass little kid.
With his eagle eyes.
Why can't you be a kid that needs glasses, huh?
I just watched that movie, A Christmas Classic.
It truly is.
Excuse me?
Oh, he saw me!
Cause he was looking to the left!
Or to the right!
I didn't notice.
What?
Six buffets.
Enough to satiate anything that moves.
Hope your tummy feels better.
Thank you, Akira.
Appreciate it.
I'm stuck?
I was stuck for a second?
Okay, hold on.
Oh my gosh.
Oh wait, no?
Waiting?
Okay.
When they look to the right, it's truly the only time I can go.
Now!
Now...
Go.
Go, go, go, go.
Hold!
Hold positions.
Wait, now I have to go...
This kind of sucks.
I now have to go all the way back.
Spent all day visiting family.
I hope you and the Wisps are having a wonderful Christmas.
The BGM got so loud all of a sudden.
Jolly?
What do I do here?
A tranq gun would be good.
I know, right?
It's kind of frustrating that it's like European extreme mode where if I get caught...
I truly don't know how to move here.
Distract him behind the pillar.
Like over here?
I didn't know if that would go as far as it did.
Okay, nice.
Where do I want to distract this guy from?
Sorry, I'm an idiot.
Hearing you sing hippopotamus for Christmas made my holiday season.
No way, really?
Glad you liked it that much.
What was that?
It's okay, we can get back there pretty quickly.
Just the wind.
Oh my god.
There we go.
Silliness averted.
What do we do about this kid though?
Oh my god, he's coming in.
Oh my god.
Turn around.
Turn around diarrhea boy.
I almost moved.
Punch him.
I wish I could.
If I could, I would.
I would not hesitate to punch the children.
If I could.
Just saying.
Would not hesitate.
Okay, it's open.
Six buffets, huh?
This looks... Wait, are these the tables?
Where is the buffet?
A kid.
What is he saying?
Oh my god.
Oh, let's eat.
Oh, so he's like, I think I can hide behind each of these.
Toast?
What did he...
What?
Why would this be useful to me?
Power?
Where did he get the jam?
What?
Oh, so here.
Toast.
This is exhilarating.
These crab cakes.
Hey, I'm the creator of this game.
What?
No way!
Thanks for checking it out.
Just wanted to let you know you missed a pretty important item in the upper right corner of the room before the boss fight.
Good luck.
Oh, thank you!
What?
No way!
Okay, we have to go head back that way then.
Important item in the... Wait, where was it?
I... The game is insane.
It has so many fun...
So many fun references.
Where was it?
Where was that?
Important item in the upper right corner of the room before the boss fight.
Okay, we gotta go back.
Wait, I need my deer head.
Oh my gosh, wait.
How am I supposed to distract these kids?
They're like the dang kids from The Shining.
Let's do here.
See ya, kid.
See ya, kids.
And then maybe...
Okay, so this is... Okay, top right.
I'm gonna go get the item.
I'm assuming it's this room over here because I think I went to the left and I just didn't explore the right.
Yeah, because I messed up.
I remember.
Nothin'?
We moonwalked?
Okay.
He's gonna look over.
Nope.
Nothing.
Merry Christmas, Mito.
Christmas outfit is so cute.
Thank you.
Yeah, I didn't realize that I could walk over here so I was like...
You little punk!
Punk ass kid.
Okay.
Okay, he's gonna look and the camera's gonna look.
Alright.
One more time.
Just my imagination.
Yeah, just your imagination.
Dummy kid.
I don't know where he goes yet.
So I'm scared.
He's not gonna walk into me, is he?
Oh my god.
So...
Oh god!
Stupid kid.
Dummy kid.
Idiot kid.
My toast!
Toast works perfectly here.
You've been in there long enough.
Yell louder.
What?
I'm sorry?
Cooties.
Yeah?
Okay, I'm going then.
There's like...
Will that be able to see me?
I got it!
Candy cane!
Why is there a camera in the toilet?
No!
What?
We've been getting drugged!
This is not true.
I don't know.
I learned a lot from video games.
Nice!
Thanks!
Thank you for...
Thank you, Dev, for telling me about this.
Okay, Columbo.
Jennifer!
Thank you for the... for the pink!
Wait, hold on.
Do I have to equip it?
Okay, yeah.
Oh my god!
I love this thing!
I had work the past three days and I was at home before that.
I can finally catch a stream again.
It was my first con and I didn't get to meet you.
No, I'm sorry!
But I took the podcast to heart and made memories.
Thank you for your wisdom and for being my OG.
I'm glad you had fun!
I didn't kill a child.
Look, he woke up.
He's fine.
He's okay.
I finally get to punch the children.
Okay, now we have to go all the way back.
But no worries.
Do you think I can, like, get two kids in a row?
Oh, whoops.
Do you think I can get two kids in a row?
How do I want to do this?
Hmm.
Music in this game is just so good.
I can't get over it.
Oh my god.
Don't come after me.
Okay.
Nice.
We made it?
Merry Christmas, Minto!
I hope it was amazing for you.
I love the outfit.
It's cute.
Thank you!
You hit a child?
Great work, boss.
Okie-dokie.
Let's see.
Oh shi...
I'm gonna have to go all the way from here.
No.
My big, my big ranking.
My big guy ranking.
How am I supposed to be a big guy now?
No.
My ranking big guy.
You're a big guy.
Oh wait.
Okay.
Oh shi...
I wish I could get past this more easily.
For you.
What do you mean for you?
I hear vertical stripes make you look bigger.
Isn't that horizontal stripes?
Oh my god.
Look up.
Look up, kid.
Run!
We made it.
Sneak 100.
Milky.
Milky room.
Little drink break.
Are you guys staying hydrated?
Okay, I wanna try something out here now.
If I'm like super fast, can I take both these kids out?
Oh nice, I can.
We're so good.
It's the forbidden yaoi in the beginning of the Dark Knight Rises.
What are you talking about?
Hey, where did the kids go that were here?
Were those the kids that I knocked out?
No.
Where did they go?
Wait, where did everybody go?
It's quiet.
Too quiet.
Hurrying.
I'm hurrying.
I wanted to use my cane on all of them.
My Nova cane.
The puns in this game are like 10 out of 10.
Wasn't there another present you...
I don't remember where that one was.
Quick props for Minto getting far without CQC.
Thanks.
Where was that other one?
The one that was just like oh yeah, you have to knock that kid out.
Even further back.
It's OK.
Maybe.
Maybe it's fine.
Maybe we'll somehow loop.
OK, now we got to toast.
Oh my gosh.
What?
Oh, I think I ran into him.
Oops.
Probably easy to get there without the kids.
True!
Wait, should we go try because...
Because there's no kids?
Wait, they might only be gone from this area though.
We can go check real quick.
We can check.
Why are we fighting kids?
These kids are under control.
They're not themselves.
Oh, I'm going to get caught.
No, I'm not.
See ya, suckers!
I'm too good.
Like the sound of the footsteps.
OK, this will be the real test to see if all the children are gone.
If the kids in this previous area are gone or not.
Oh wait, it wasn't this area.
Oh, what was it?
This area?
Oh no, see, they're still there.
OK, I don't feel like... Sorry guys, I don't feel like going so, so far back.
It's OK, it was good to check though.
It's good to check.
You're pretty good.
Oops, my bad.
No, it was a good idea, I think.
I think it was worth checking.
I think it was worth looking into.
Imagine if they were just like, yeah, all the kids on the entire game are just gone.
That'd be wild.
You could just go wherever you please.
You can just go anywhere you please.
Bloop, bloop, bloop, bloop, bloop, bloop, bloop.
Alrighty.
Seems like these ones are fine.
OK.
Minky goes to the mall.
Merry Chrysler, Minto.
Merry Chrysler!
It's quiet in here.
Too quiet.
Oh, a present.
We got a box!
He's like my cat.
Don't you?
Sneakypedia!
I'm not watching another one of those again.
No, Snake.
This has nothing to do with my Japanese animes.
Sokoku, or locked country, refers to Japan's old foreign relations policy.
Under Sokoku, no Japanese were allowed to leave the country.
At the same time, no foreigners were allowed into the country.
Remarkably, it marked one of the longest periods of peace in Japanese history.
Oh, brother.
I can see he's been reading the sneaky page on Japan again.
By sealing yourself in a cardboard box without air holes, you'll be isolating yourself from the outside.
That includes all of the good, but also all of the bad.
I'll still be able to use the box as a stealth device though, right?
That's right.
As long as you're standing still, you'll be disguised to look just like an ordinary cardboard box.
No, this is easier I think to use than the deer.
Be careful though.
Don't let any enemies get too close, or your disguise will be ineffective.
Stay out of the enemy's path.
Got it.
Be careful not to forget to unequip the box when it's not in use.
To breathe.
Wait, actually?
I can't breathe in this thing?
What's wrong?
Uh-oh.
It looks like you've got company.
No!
Watch out, Snake.
That's the Tengu Advanced Defense Patrol Operations Lightning Espionage Unit.
Why is it so long?
Most people just call them the Tadpoles.
Oh, it's the Tadpoles!
Tadpoles are a highly specialized PNC group, notorious for their lightning-quick reflexes and unparalleled dexterity.
Funny, they look just like little girls to me.
Well, they are little girls.
Ballerinas to be precise.
Why does this feel so Kids Next Door sometimes?
Not that I can remember.
Believe me, these kids would give you an unforgettable performance of the Nutcracker, so you'd better not let them get too close.
The Tadpoles wear special Tadpro Stealth Suits, made from a synthetic semi-liquid material called Tadpolyester.
Tadpolyester!
The Tadpolyester acts as a lubricating agent, eliminating almost all friction between the joints.
This allows for total fluidity in motion.
Lubrication also prevents anyone from getting a firm grip on its surface.
So no CQC.
Dang.
No!
Like a ballet dance, every Tadpole's position is choreographed by a central controlling entity called the Level Designer.
These instructions are then communicated to each individual Tadpole via nanomachines.
Why do the children have nanomachines?
To miss a mark could spell disaster for the rest of the team.
That's why Tadpoles are injected with a blocker enzyme that prevents them from straying from the Level Designer's plan.
So distractions are out of the question.
OK.
I'd say your best bet is to sneak out of there using your cardboard box.
Try to anticipate the Tadpole's movements and avoid being caught in their path.
OK.
With a little luck, you should be able to find a hole in their patrol path and sneak your way out.
Good luck.
Oh no!
They are also British!
He's gotta be the police O2 use.
Oh no way.
Cleo!
Keep going.
Oh shoot.
Oh my god.
Uh-oh.
Go girl, go.
Please leave.
No!
Please leave!
Oh my god, I'm gonna die.
OK.
Understood.
OK, but I know where I can go.
I know I can go here.
Oh Cleo!
OK, now I probably can box.
Why can't I breathe in the cardboard box?
Oh!
Wait, how did I do that before?
I don't remember.
There's no air holes.
I know, but also...
Box.
OK.
We can get through once she turns around and walks.
Nice.
And back to toast.
Okey dokey.
Easy peasy lemon squeezy.
I think it's this one, right?
Yeah.
Okey dokey.
Nice.
I'm just following.
Where are we going?
OK, find an elevator to the first floor.
There's like...oh we're going this way now.
Oh we can use our box here.
That's so fun.
Yeah!
Gotcha!
OK.
Box and...
No you don't.
Nice.
Gotcha!
East.
OK, I'm going.
Where are we?
All the way down there.
OK.
I'm watching the children's movements.
So...
I just noticed.
OK.
I'm gonna become a deer.
Oh deer.
Oh and then they switch.
OK OK.
Good to know.
And then they're gonna switch.
I think.
Yeah yeah yeah.
OK.
Nice.
I'm just gonna run for it.
What's over here?
What's over here though?
Is there anything?
Oh!
They're looking!
There's a present up there!
CQC.
I forgot I had it.
Make checkpoint first.
You are so smart, Revaldi!
You are so smart.
Nice.
Now we got a checkpoint.
And I'm gonna...
Get my cane!
Oh!
Sorry kid.
I'm gonna grab this before they wake up.
Oh we got another box!
Yes!
Oh my god!
It has an arrow!
Oh.
Breathing hole.
Yippee!
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Oh.
What?
No, that's so messed up!
I pressed CTRL!
I pressed CTRL.
NA equals...
Wait, do I have it though?
Why am I in the box?
Wait, why am I in the box?
Wait, I have it though!
Oh!
Nevermind.
We don't need to go back at all.
Okay.
The game is forgiving.
And so I'm going to switch to my box with air.
I feel like there was a similar room in the first one.
Like this.
Nice!
Where's the box for...
Wait, where's the box with holes for sushi?
What?
No, that's just craziness.
That's like, too much, you know?
Yeah, there was one.
Right, yeah, I thought so.
Oh, that kid scared me.
Is this not an elevator right here?
I'm wall gliding.
Can I go to the bathroom?
No, okay.
Does this kid come up?
No.
I might... I might take him out though.
Let's take him out.
What is this?
Oops.
Oh my god.
If I box...
Does it help me sneak?
Yes.
A gift?
Outer saving?
Yeah, we are at the mall.
Oh.
The roof?
Wait, seriously?
Wait, where was the roof?
Roof.
Okay, we are just going to follow the yellow light.
There we go.
That was a close one.
The top of the building, silly.
Where was the top of the building?
We are going to get this kid, we are going to knock him out, we are going to knock him dead.
Nothing?
Just a box?
You made a mistake, kid.
I made a mistake, kid!
It was me.
I made the mistake.
No!
I
don't know what this kid's pattern is, it kind of freaks me out.
I love being a box.
Mint made what Matara would call a mistaki.
Oh yeah, she does call it that, doesn't she?
She made a mistaki.
Mistaki?
At least these kids aren't tough to get by, it's just a little, you know...
Okay, I'm following the line.
Okay, I'm following...
Wait, oh no, I have to go back down!
I don't think I can...
Yeah, this is a wall.
Shoot.
That's okay.
We got the box.
Oh no, they are going to hear.
I just...
Don't worry about it.
Come here, kid.
Come over this way.
Actually, you can go up.
Here we go.
What?
How did they notice me?
Oh my God.
No!
I won't let you find me this time.
Surveillance camera.
Gotcha!
I'm a box forever.
I'm just a box.
I'm a box forever, you guys.
Alright, we go all the way down and around...
Oh yeah, there's no kids here still.
Okay, that's kind of not so bad then.
They all left.
Okay, I still have to get past this thing, but...
I guess it could be worse.
Makes me wish I hadn't done the backtracking before, you know?
Wait, is it going to be actual booties for my...
Like actual little socks for my booties?
I wonder.
Hi, Mint.
Hello!
Hello, hello.
I wonder if we're going to get to that room that I...
The room that I was trying to get to before.
Stockings, perhaps.
Perhaps.
Stockings.
Little sprite snake is so cute.
Let's see.
Oh, I hate this room though.
My least favorite room.
Oh my god.
He doesn't... No!
My least favorite room.
They mimic the T-Rex.
He has pretty T-Rex, huh?
Oh wait, actually I'm going to become a deer for this one.
Okay.
Okay, we're good.
They're dumb kids.
They don't know anything.
They don't know how to look over corners.
No!
Hello?
Are you going to move?
There we go.
I think I'm good here.
Alrighty.
Okay, where the heck are we?
Where are we?
There's this guy.
Oh wait, this is where we can... This is where the item was before.
I remember now.
Wait.
Wait, wait.
There we go.
And then I'm going to Nova Cannon.
This isn't the item he meant, right?
I guess I don't need to beat this guy, so...
Oops.
Merry Freaky Christmas Minky YouTube!
I tried taking him out.
So you can't really take him out if you're like...
If you're like next to him, you know?
I hate these kids.
I hope they all have coal in their stockings for the rest of their lives!
And their after lives!
Why can't I walk in the mall?
Am I not a citizen?
Is this not a place?
Wait.
Oh my god.
What did you hear?
What the hell did you hear?
Excuse me?
What
the hell did you hear?
Did he see me?
He didn't see me, did he?
How did he see me so far away?
If only I had taken that kid out, everything would have been fine!
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my gosh.
Take him out.
Okay, that guy's asleep.
Now we'll take this guy out.
He like goes all the way down to the bottom though.
I don't know why.
Got him!
Okay!
H.I.
We got it!
Before that, I accidentally assassinated St. Nick.
Holistic delusion.
Stop with the nerd talk, Otacon.
Great,
but how's this going to help with the mission?
Okay.
Well, when you put it that way.
I'm so confused.
That was a lot of talking for something so...
Oh, this kid's awake again.
Let's see.
Box.
Oh god, he's awake!
We're going over.
Oh shoot.
You heard nothing?
Don't worry about it, kid.
Oh, you're looking this way now?
These kids are too concerned with other people's issues.
I'm just saying.
It's not your issue.
You don't need to be concerned.
Okay?
Gosh, we are really backtracking so far.
Oh my gosh, how much further do we need to go?
Oh my gosh.
Does he look up?
I think I go down?
The gift includes fast travel too?
Thank you.
For the, I guess...
Oh my god.
Thank you for the heads up.
Oh, it's the other side.
Wait, what is it?
This is the bathroom, right?
Was there anything in here?
Is there anything in here or is it just kids peeing?
Men can't even go to the bathroom without getting caught.
Wait, there is a special call.
No!
That's our reward.
It's horrible.
Okay, at least it's not so bad on the eyes, you know?
Did he wash his hands?
He absolutely did not.
Gotcha!
Oh yeah, that's right.
There is this kid.
Gotcha!
Oh yeah, there was these three kids too.
Nice.
And then this guy who scared me in the beginning.
Hope you had a good holiday, Mito.
You too!
Thanks, Brandon!
Brandon!
Ping Pong!
Toast.
That's right.
This kid is guarding this place pretty well.
Oh, it's all the way over there.
I see it.
Oh, he didn't hear that.
Oops.
How am I supposed to get him to hear though?
He didn't hear it.
Maybe if I box here?
Let's see.
Maybe he will look in the corner.
OK.
Nice.
Oh, that's right.
He just kind of turns around whenever he feels like.
I'm scared he's going to wake up.
OK, I'm going.
I suck!
What are you doing with the stocking-stocking again?
The stocking-stocking is...
This was supposed to help me get past metal floors, but it's all ruined because of the eyeballs I made to wear it over my head.
Wait, you wore the stocking-stocking over your head?
Well, yeah.
I mean, I figured I was supposed to wear it like a balaclava.
Oh, Snake, no!
You did it silly!
Yeah, but this was supposed to help me walk over metal floors without making any noise.
Surely we could work backwards and figure out how we'd do such a thing.
I get it.
Like six degrees of separation.
Right.
So this is a holy sock.
What are some other holy things you know?
Holy sock.
Foxholes, airholes, wormholes, plot holes.
Buttholes.
This is no good.
Take a look at your other items.
OK.
Maybe there's a running theme going on.
Well, a lot of my items are Christmassy.
Great.
So what are some Christmas things that are holy?
Merry Christmas!
Happy Boo Year!
Thank you, Rika!
Oh, brother.
Yippee!
Oh, nice.
So where's the quick travel?
We gotta go all the way back, huh?
Oh my god, that kid just woke up.
Oh my god.
Nothing?
Just red.
Just go snake.
Alright, let's put on my sock.
Oh my god, he's coming all the way over here!
Oh!
So I think I...
I knocked here.
An emerald box.
There isn't.
You misread.
Wait, what do you mean I misread?
Someone said that it comes with a fast...
The gift will be fast travel too.
Merry Christmas Mint.
Hope you're feeling better tonight.
Thank you!
Oh, they said I hope.
I also hoped.
Oh man.
Gotcha!
Okay.
Maybe it won't be so bad since we have ways to knock kids out and also ways to get over floors and stuff now.
So maybe it won't be so long.
Where am I going again?
Like here?
Oh yeah, down there.
That was so close.
Phew!
Through here.
Okay.
We had hoped everybody.
Unfortunately, our dreams did not come true.
We did get an extra item.
That's kind of fun.
We got the Thermal Goggles.
Aren't you guys... That's like your favorite item.
We got the most important thing, right?
That's so important.
Christmas is saved!
Saved!
My favorite room!
Actually...
I think if I use the socks here...
Ah!
Snake!
I'm so bad at avoiding this part.
Stinking children, man.
I swear to God.
What's going on?
Let's see.
Let's keep going.
I could have socked there.
There was a point I could have socked.
Okay, hold on.
It's like coming up.
They align perfectly.
I think here.
No.
No!
We're almost back to where we were.
I think the next couple of parts don't have kids.
Well, besides like...
Besides the kids at the bottom of the stairs, but we can just knock those kids out.
I thought I heard my cat.
I don't think I did.
We can just knock these kids out, baby!
And then everything else should be...
With no kids.
The double kill.
Yeah, kill kids.
He says don't stab them in the throat with the candy cane, but...
It's the most effective weapon.
Or wait, it's the most effective way!
I love these remixes of the...
Of the themes, they're so great.
It's only a mild concussion.
Yeah, concussion.
Okay,
we're almost back guys.
We're almost there.
Gotcha!
So glad we have the box with the air holes now.
What was that one floor...
Remember there was a floor with gas and...
What else was in there?
Gas and electrified floors and everything?
What happened to that place?
My socks.
Now my box.
I don't think they...
Alright.
And now my socks.
Nice.
We're doing so good.
We're doing it guys.
We're doing it.
And now...
I don't know if I need the box here, but I'd like to.
I think I do actually.
Otherwise they'll see me.
I touched him!
Otherwise they'll see me in the peripheral.
No socks.
It's such an old man thing to wear.
It's the socks, you know.
Having the socks is such an old man thing.
Compression socks.
Okay, so we gotta go all the way down there.
We've got this.
Now we've got socks so we don't even have to be careful.
We can be reckless and wild.
We can be unhinged.
We can be...
Crazy!
And we can hit kids.
Like that.
Now we have our socks.
Is this little punk?
Oh no.
He's not doing anything.
Wait, what's this?
A P-Gun?
We got the Polar Gun!
I love the Antarctic!
Why are they in the Antarctic?
Now that's what I'm talking about.
God,
these references are great.
Oh my god, that's insane.
What's that?
They hibernate, don't they?
And then they hibernated?
Oh no!
Oops.
Freaky.
Okay.
Six shots.
Probably.
Yeah, probably.
Oh, so my ammo is full.
Guys, I got to go use the little ghosties room real quick.
Is that okay?
I'm so sorry.
It's about all this tea I've been drinking.
I'll be right back.
You guys be good.
Wait, hold on.
We got to make this Christmas themed.
Instead of gone fishing, what should we do for Christmas theme?
Gone Carolyn!
Carolyn.
Who's Carolyn?
Gone Carolyn.
Jingle bells, jingle bells, jingle all the way.
I
forgot to unmute.
I'm back.
There we go.
Alright guys, let's get back into it.
So we got our gun.
So now I can shoot the kids, which is very exciting.
And I'm excited to do that.
I'm going to shoot them till they freeze.
Where is our polar gun?
Wouldn't it be safer though to candy cane the kid?
I feel.
Wouldn't it be safer to candy kid though?
Candy kid.
We'll just use it when we need it.
Especially if we only have six shots.
Six shots.
Oh, you see me?
No you don't.
Liar.
This kid is a liar.
What are you doing kid?
What are you looking around for?
Trying to figure out where I go and what I do.
Oh gosh, someone else saw me.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, okay.
I can't just sit here then.
I have to be real sneaky.
Shoot.
Oh gosh.
Nothing?
Yup, exactly.
Dummy kid.
We got to go down, but...
Okay.
CQC him.
I don't know what's patterned yet though.
Oh
my god, that scared me!
Oh my gosh.
That was so Hueycore.
What do you mean by that?
Holy moly.
Holy night.
He turns around so fast, this kid.
Okay,
and then he looks back.
Alright, we'll wait for him to walk over.
Oh gosh, we need our socks here.
We need our socks here.
Alright, sock.
And sock again.
How do I want to do this?
Maybe I...
Well, if I do it, will one see me?
I wonder.
Like if I go down, I mean, and CQC the kid, the other kid will see me.
Probably.
So I should knock here and then run over here and box.
I hate this kid!
I hate you!
What the hell kid?
Why don't you do exactly as I predict you to do?
Why don't you listen to me?
Listen to your father!
Stupid ass kid.
Stupid kid.
We are following after this kid.
Oh my chat is frozen.
Give me a second.
How do you pause in this game?
Besides just holding down.
I don't know actually.
Well that is why I need to learn how to pause.
Codec?
Probably, right?
Probably, probably, probably.
Okay, hold on.
I'm...
Just finished the new levels of Freak or Treat.
The new cameos and references are great.
You've really been spoiling us.
Hope your tummy feels better soon.
Hope you have a good holiday.
Thank you Brick!
I'm glad you liked it!
Oh, thank you for reminding me.
Oh my gosh.
Hold on, I was fixing my chat.
There we go.
For those who don't know, I have a game that I have out called Freak or Treat.
I made it, well I didn't make it, but you know, me and my team.
We did it for Halloween.
We recently added 12 new levels.
So lots and lots of levels.
I should add it to my description.
Now that I think about it.
I hate this kid.
I can't believe he saw me from so far away.
Eagle-eyed punk.
I'm gonna make sure you have... Next time you're not gonna have eyes.
Little asshole.
How do I wanna do this?
I
don't know where to knock.
Use the metal floor for a more safe distraction?
You're so right.
Don't.
Don't do it.
No.
Oh god.
Oh my gosh, that was so close.
We made it.
Too good at this game.
Merry Christmas.
Thank you for spending Christmas, a romantic holiday in Japan with us, your Wisps.
Does that mean you love us?
Does it look like I'm in Japan, Brian?
Are you in Japan, Brian?
That's what I thought.
Alright, where... Oh gosh, we need to go all the way down there.
Alright,
let's suck.
And...
I ran into him instead.
I'm in Japan, so it's very romantic.
I'm sorry for you.
I'm so sorry for you.
I didn't think he'd see me.
First he sucked across the floor, then he sucked the kid.
Yeah, exactly.
Except I didn't realize he'd be able to see me.
Didn't realize he'd be able to see me.
Right there.
Actually, maybe we don't have to suck him.
Maybe I can just do this.
Okay, bye!
Yeah, exactly.
Go investigate, silly kid.
Oh my god!
I didn't think it would see me.
What?
That was craziness.
It's okay, we can get back pretty quickly.
I'm afraid of going...
Oh wait.
Oh my god.
I'm afraid of when to go.
Um...
Okay, I see my window of opportunity.
Here.
Oh, but I... Okay, okay, okay.
Alright, alright.
We have to...
Oh, it's tricky.
What does this kid do?
Nothing?
You just stand here?
You just be a kid?
You just be a little weirdo kid?
Yeah.
Actually, I'm gonna be a deer here.
Mike!
Thank you so much for the pink!
I mean, don't marry Xmas.
I heard that you're such a hag...
that in the bible's version of a Christmas carol, you were the ghost of Christmas past to Jesus Christ himself.
This elevator is busted too.
I'm all out of ideas, Snake.
Why is every single elevator in this mall broken?
What's up with this place?
What's this?
Hey man, can you please keep it down?
I'm trying to sleep.
Then leave!
Leave!
The Nova Kid is in your right hand.
Why are you punching them with your left chest?
Oh my god, we just got a missile?
Wait, can I actually blow up the kids now?
Hello?
I don't think I want to kiss the children, Otacon.
Which you can then control with your arrow keys.
Kissels?
Missile Toe Launcher?
This is ridiculous.
Why should I believe a single thing you've said?
Well, because if you don't, you'll end up blowing up a lot of them.
Alright, alright, I believe you.
One last thing.
The Missile Toe Launcher can only hold one kissel at a time.
So once you fire it, you'll have to find more kissels around the mall.
What am I supposed to do with this?
With that Missile Toe Launcher, you should be able to destroy the electrical switchboard.
It's in that room filled with gas.
Oh god, where was that?
By destroying the electrical switchboard, you deactivate all the electrical floors in that area.
You should head back up to the 20th floor.
From there, you can access an elevator that will take you down to the 10th floor.
What's on the 10th floor?
An elevator you can take all the way down to the...
If I miss...
If I miss, I have to come all the way back here for ammo?
No.
No way.
Just don't miss.
Some people are saying it's any ammo.
So like if I just find something like random ammo around...
Wait, I have to go all the way back though?
Wait, there's only like one ammo that I've seen and all like...
Wait, how am I supposed to get this kid?
Oh, I guess like... Hold on.
When he walks back, I'll kill him.
Not kill him, sorry.
I'm not killing kids.
Yeah, don't...
Don't worry.
That was close.
Can I get this guy?
No, I'm not gonna be...
How do I want to get this guy?
You know what?
I'm gonna try.
Oh, fuck me!
You fucking kids, where are your parents?
I hate the children.
Oh wait, I did it wrong.
I'm an idiot.
Sorry, I just realized.
I'm the shifty deer.
Hey, hey, don't go close to the wall.
Stupid kid.
I'm the shifty deer.
I'm gonna get shifted every year.
Stupid kid.
No guilt is harm...
Turn around!
Oh, don't go up.
Okay, nevermind.
You know what?
I don't know why I didn't just sneak past you before.
The novocade is in your right hand.
Stop!
This section is so annoying.
So let's try kissing these kids.
With the missile.
Let's try firing a missile at them.
Hit the target out with the power of love.
Hold down ctrl to look down the sights and release the fire.
Wow, it's really shaky.
I'm so dead.
Sneak 100.
No way.
Oh my goodness gracious.
Scary.
Okay, all the way...
All the way back.
No wonder this game has such a much longer run time.
Don't question where the box came from.
Wait, how the hell am I supposed to get past these kids?
Can I not take this up here?
Shoot it with the kissel.
Do I shoot it?
I'm just trying to exist here.
No.
No!
This kid!
I'm hoping this reloads every time.
Is this a...
Oh my gosh, this is... It shoots so fast.
You guys, it shoots so fast.
Is that the electrical board?
I don't even know.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's so fast.
I don't know if that's the electrical board right there.
This kid, I'm gonna murder you for real.
How do I wanna be...
Where do I want to be?
I think it's that.
Maybe here.
It's okay.
Then I still have to... If I run out of ammo, it's such a pain in the butt.
That's a vent?
It is?
It's a...
It looks like a vent, but it's like...
Oopsie.
Okay, a box.
I have to go all the way to the room with the cats to get rid of all the electric boards.
Okay.
How do I get past these kids?
Ugly kids.
Oh god.
I'm trying to figure out how I get past these two right here.
Knock him out.
Yeah, I think I need to.
I'm pressing control, but it...
There we go.
Wait, I think he's gonna come down through here, isn't he?
I hate this stupid ass kid.
I can't wait to murder you.
This will be your last Christmas.
It's your last Christmas.
It's your last Christmas and it's your very last Christmas.
Say goodb... wait.
I didn't get both kids!
Actually,
I'm just gonna hang out right here.
Where is it?
Here.
Okay, now we got both of them.
Okay.
Goodness.
Thank goodness.
Stop it!
We can't do this anymore.
I'm so...
This part is so frustrating!
Frustrating!
I got a box right here.
Oh my god.
Real Joker moment.
Joker moment real.
Real Joker moment!
Joker moment!
I'm gonna become the Joker!
He walks on the tiles, right?
Okay, yeah.
Why not use the... shit.
Shit shit shit shit shit shit shit.
He's not coming down here, right?
Okay, good.
This guy is really hard because he moves so fast.
This one over here.
I'm trying to figure out how I wanna deal with him.
I could... You know what?
I think I'll have to Nikita Missile him.
Once this guy walks past.
Okay.
Missile.
N!
You stinking ugly children!
God!
Wait, do I have...
Okay, good.
I still have the one missile that they give me.
The singular missile that they give me.
What's up with this kid chilling over here anyway?
Oh my god!
Okay.
Alright.
And then... Wait, not the sock.
Sorry, not yet.
He's on break.
I guess that's... I guess that's fair.
I'm all for any kids that don't bother me.
This game is gonna make me the Grinch.
We're fine.
Oh my god.
I'm stuck trying to get past the wall.
That was so close.
Yeah!
Okay, now we go...
Oh look!
Wait, were these ammos here before?
Or are these all new?
I think actually.
I think these are all new.
I think.
Yeah, I think.
So that's kind of nice.
Ever since he got the gun.
I'm sock.
I'm socks.
Socks.
Nice.
Oh shit.
Nothing?
Please.
Thank you.
Oh look, there's one here.
Gotcha.
I think that's electrified floors too.
If I'm looking at those correctly.
Okay.
We're past that part.
Holy moly.
Okay, well, just why not still be a box.
There's no bad part of being a box, eh?
We're just boxin' along, boxin' along, boxin' along.
There's no kids here.
It's pretty nice.
I love adult-free or kid-free places, you know.
When they're like, no kids allowed at this resort.
That's how I feel this area is.
It's so nice.
Boxing day is tomorrow.
Oh my gosh, wait, you're right.
Okay.
But man, thanks very much.
Memories broken, the truth goes unspoken.
I've even forgotten my name.
Wait, what's my name?
Oh no!
What was that?
I miss Sam.
I miss him.
I miss him so much.
Ammo full.
At least they give you ammo now.
It's so nice.
It's my favorite spot!
You guys, it's my favorite area!
It's my favorite area!
Run, run, run!
You guys, I've been thinking like...
I'll be honest.
I really don't want to play Metal Gear Acid.
But I know I feel like I have to.
To complete my Metal Gear adventure.
But I just really don't want to.
How did you see me?
I really don't want to.
Wait, what did I just press?
Continue.
Oh my god, that scared the hell out of me.
That scared me so bad.
I'm gonna deer mask instead.
I think that was the best option here.
That's the deer mask.
Oh my god!
Run, run, run!
Oh, it's this part.
Oh my god.
Is Acid like a card game?
It is.
It's like Kingdom Hearts...
Chain of Memories.
If you know, you know.
I hate this kid here.
So I don't know if I'll play it.
Maybe then go to...
Go into...
Actually, why don't I just do this?
This would be so much faster.
I don't know why I'm sticking around.
Um...
But yeah, I might go.
I don't know if I'll do Acid or if I'll just play Metal Gear Solid 4 once I'm back.
One or the other.
Oh, this is the room!
With that missile tow launcher you should be able to destroy the electrical switchboard.
It's in that room filled with gas.
It's filled with gas.
I'm with my parents watching your stream and they're listening to you scream at kids.
Merry Christmas.
Hi parents!
I'm not naughty.
I'm very good.
Okay, the Nikita missile though might be the end of me.
How do I...
Oops.
How do I get this?
Oh my god.
Yeah, Santa told me yesterday I was nice.
I was on the nice list.
What?
No, this is impossible.
Yo, how am I supposed to get past everything?
There's no slowdown option, I don't think.
Hold on, let me see.
Hold down control to look down the sights and release the fire.
Control the missile.
Nope, there's no slowdown.
Oh my god, no.
Santa said that shortly after you sang about burning your wisps.
No, what?
It was a song.
You don't appreciate art?
Eyes!
Now we can use...
We can use... what's it called?
A no-breathe box.
We absolutely gamed, let's go.
Nice.
There's some children here.
OK.
Wait, where am I going?
Oh, I have to go up through there.
So we... oh gosh.
OK, we come here.
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
It attracts everybody?
Nice.
Maybe it's kind of awesome that it attracted everybody actually.
Yippee!
What if I had my toast?
It's not jammed now.
If it works, it works.
I totally planned that.
Just saying.
Oh my god.
That's our chocolate!
Thanks for the 50 gifted!
Thank you!
If the dev is still here, if you make a Merry Gears Solid 3, I want to be in your game.
Let me voice in your game.
Please.
Is this an official game?
No, it's a fan game.
Cookie eater?
Not gonna happen!
No!
No, we got shut down so fast.
Is it because I keep talking about wanting to kill the children?
I'm sorry.
Sorry, I'm a violent ghost.
I enjoy all the killing.
That's why.
Wait.
What's...oh it's this kid.
Merry, merry, merry...
You saw nothing kid.
Yep!
Exactly!
Exactly.
Just your imagination, little kid.
Mariano!
Thank you so much for the fit together.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Now we have a Joy to the World included in the remix.
I love it.
Do, do, do, do.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh no!
Wait, what do you mean?
No.
What's that supposed to mean?
That's scary.
Panther!
Thank you for another 50!
Thank you so much!
Yeah.
Right.
Can I attack them?
Oh no!
I'm Santa!
Mariano, thank you for the fit!
Ducky, thanks for the party!
Maizo, thank you for the fit!
Oh.
Snake!
Just a box.
What happened?
Stalking, stalking.
It's so funny.
Oh my God!
I don't hear any music.
Music!
Wait, can I flip in this form too?
Oh, no ghosts?
I was gone.
Okay, the ghosts are gone.
Okay.
I've become a sim.
I'm ready to woohoo!
Any other sims around wanting to woohoo?
Where are my clothes?
No way!
Stop!
It's the house!
I recognize this house!
It's the house from the first game!
Stop!
Doom, doom, doo, doo, doom, doom.
The Ghost of Christmas Past, yeah!
What do you mean by that?
Looking for my clothes.
No children in sight.
Wandering around naked in this house.
What the hell is this?
Oh yeah, this is to avoid the lasers there.
Wait, I don't have any items.
Okay.
Following in his footsteps.
Bravo, Kojumbo.
It lags a little bit though.
I can't tell if that's the game or my computer.
Interesting.
Oh gosh.
I'm just going to walk through?
Okay, easy.
Easy.
Merry Christmas, Mito.
Merry Christmas!
Oh my god, MGS4.
Oh my god!
The MGS4 flashback.
When you go back to Shadow Moses.
Stop!
The idea that a bunch of little ballerina girls fully undress Snake is kind of freaky.
Don't say it like that!
I didn't know that.
This music is so dramatic.
I wonder if this game was made...
I mean, Merry Gear Solid 2 was made before MGSV.
Because...
Are the tadpoles supposed to be the skull unit?
Or are they supposed to be... I mean, I imagine they're supposed to be the beauties.
Right?
I guess.
It was made before V.
They're the frogs.
The frogs from MGS... What are the frogs in MGS4?
What the hell is the frog unit?
What the hell are the frogs?
I don't remember these guys at all.
All the guys apparently in it was fighting.
I'm thinking of... Wait, the beauties though.
I don't remember their names.
I don't remember the frogs.
Fake fan.
I'm a fake fan.
Oh my clothes!
My Santa suit.
Santa suit.
No!
Wait, what?
So true.
He said minutes, but the subtitle said seconds.
I got all my stuff back.
Wait, so... Hold on, I want to see.
Why is it so laggy?
Hopefully this doesn't...
I think I know which game Mint's playing after break.
Yeah, apparently I need to play MGS3 again.
I mean, sorry, 4.
I only remember the beauties.
And I remember... OK.
To be fair...
There's like 2 guys that I don't know at all.
There's like 2 randos.
What are they?
Policenaut...
Reference guys...
In the unit.
And then also...
All I remember is anytime you see Meryl's unit, Johnny's shitting his pants.
That's all I remember, OK?
Whenever I see them...
Johnny's just... Johnny's literally a snatcher.
Sorry, it was snatcher, not policenaut, yeah.
And then...
It's really the beauties that steal the show.
Because they...
Oh my gosh, why is it so slow?
You fight the beauties and then you get the whole trauma dump from Drebin.
It's not that I've forgotten completely.
It's just they're not important.
The frog unit's not important.
Thank you for the 10 gifted thank you.
Oh my god.
Guys, I feel like Old Snake for real.
Oh, I'm Old Snake for real.
Oh my god.
Oh, we're outside.
I'm Cold Snake if his limbs got frozen.
Shut up!
What?
Merry Gear!
It looks like a postman.
A sniper.
Christmas yet to come.
Stop.
It's like a pun.
We just pun after pun and pun attack.
Father Christmas.
Ah!
Frosty Frost?
Wait, what?
It's pure.
It's a pure idea.
Cool.
The Santa Claus?
Oh my god!
No!
But what if someone else still thought of him?
I can't.
But we still haven't figured out the last passcode.
Time to seal your fate.
Do I
just shoot him?
Oh my god.
It's so...
Oh, guys.
You guys.
I can't move at all.
Why is my game like this?
It's so laggy.
It's so laggy, you guys.
I don't even have bullets now.
Can you restart the game?
Oh, sorry.
I just stopped.
It seems like all of the ghosts are delivery men of some kind.
Turn off ray tracing.
Well,
you asked for a slowdown.
I'm a box to be delivered!
That didn't work, you guys.
Oh, gosh.
I'm afraid if I...
I'm afraid if I quit the game.
What if it doesn't save?
Should we take the risk?
Should we take the risk and exit out the game?
Hold on.
Let me go back inside, maybe.
I don't know how to manually save, you guys.
I don't know how to access the menu.
I can't go back inside, so...
What if I just do this?
Hold on.
I just noticed the mailbox.
Do you think he'll come here?
There's a package!
Oh, God.
Okay, I'm gonna close out the game.
Okay, here we go.
Let's see!
Oh, I'm nervous!
Should I auto-save?
Oh, sorry.
It's teeny tiny.
I have to adjust it.
I don't know where I had it before.
Press CTRL to skip the codec whenever the... Oh, thank you!
Okay, continue?
Ah, perfect!
Yay!
Also, guys, don't fault the game.
It's old, so it's all good.
Firetruck, welcome to membership.
Turn off the game console.
Yay!
Okay.
Alright, now we have to...
Okay, he gets me every time.
Oops.
It seems like all of the ghosts are delivery men of some kind.
And disgruntled ones at that.
Maybe there is some way you can use his occupation against him.
Kind of like you did with the milkman.
Watch, the game is so old that you need to e-mail yourself an AOL e-mail.
And you need the You Got Mail sound to play and he'll hear it.
And then he'll come out and you can get him.
You got mail.
I don't think going by the mailbox works.
How do I get him to come out?
Hello!
I'm an unassuming...
Okay, let's try the missile now since I can.
He shoots down my missile!
Hello!
You got mail.
He's too good.
Oh wait, let me try.
Maybe if I hit it...
Can I lift the little thingy on it?
Knock on the mailbox.
Oh, knock on it.
Let's try it.
Maybe if... Can I knock on it from the front?
Let me try.
Something to...
Something to... I feel like it has to be with the box, right?
Because...
Because that makes the most sense.
It could be the other box.
I don't know if it makes a difference.
Anything on thermals.
No?
Maybe I can shoot it.
We're gonna try everything we got.
Box on the doorstep.
That's a good idea too.
I would love to be delivered...
To the family.
Go around the building.
I don't think you can.
No?
Knock on the door.
Delivery!
If anybody knows, can I get a hint?
I can't get any closer to him, so I'm like...
It's really silly.
Really silly?
Really?
Walk with the box.
I tried that before.
It didn't work.
Really silly.
Really silly?
I'll show you guys.
Just so you know.
Call Otacon again?
I'll call... Yeah, let's try it.
I'm trying!
I'm a box.
I'm a box to be delivered.
I'm a box to be delivered!
Please!
Come out!
Come here!
Come get me!
Oops, I didn't mean to press C.
Uh-huh.
My socks?
Something to do with my socks?
Is he jealous of... Does he like my socks?
Polar gun him.
I don't think that's gonna work, but I will try it.
Wait.
It's just a waste of my bullets.
Do I put my socks in the mail?
Does he want to smell my feet?
Call again?
Yeah, we'll just wait until he tells us the answer.
Yeah.
Doesn't make much sense though.
He's like...
Huh?
Wait.
I was gonna... Yeah!
Ah!
I see it!
Yes!
I knew it!
Grandad!
Package.zip!
Oh my gosh!
Shut up!
Oh my God!
That's so funny!
But I can shoot a grenade that far.
Wait.
OK
Pumble him to the ground!
Tiny Tim!
Oh my God!
Tragic Tim.
In the first place.
Another wrench?
No.
No I didn't.
Yeah, I did notice that.
I did notice that.
Oh my God!
Did you try 1, 2, 2, 5?
Blah, blah.
What a twist.
The Ghost of Christmas Past.
There are so many Nicks and Santas and Juniors.
Juniors and...
I mean that would be actually really great.
No!
Not the VR training!
There it is!
The MGS2 twist.
No!
But the children love Christmas.
That's not something you'll ever have to worry about.
Wait!
Don't we have...don't we have Timmy?
What were his last words?
That was it!
Cold Snake.
Otacon.
Children.
Sorry Tadpoles, I forgot who you guys were.
Cindy Luhu.
Wait, we never figured out who that was.
Jack Frost, Nick Junior, Tragic Tim.
Yeah, I thought there would be a third boss.
That was so great though.
Especially like the ways that you really had to think outside the box for...
For the boss fight.
So awesome.
Maybe a post credit sequence.
I think so, I think so.
I mean...oh.
See!
Huh!
Aww.
Huh?
Huh!
Ahh!
Hahaha!
He's even...he's got like the...the headband.
But it's his hat.
Oh.
Ahh!
Yeah, it did seem a bit hard to believe that your brain could have managed to remain intact after a shot in the head.
So in the end, it all had to do with belief, huh?
The belief.
Yeah!
Tim used it to deceive the ghosts of Christmas past and to end Christmas once and for all.
But in the end, it was your beliefs that prevailed.
I don't see what my beliefs have to do with anything.
The Santa Claus, Snake.
This entire mission would have been for naught had it not been for your belief in my existence.
That's why you gotta believe in ghosts.
The Santa Claus.
Oh my god.
Secret Santa.
I can see why there won't be a third one.
A third game.
Merry Christmas Santa Claus!
I feel you approaching.
I've waited all year.
Oh my god.
Trust no one, not even Santa Claus.
Yeah!
That was crazy!
More credits.
Are we getting after credits?
After credits.
Credits.
After, wait.
After after credits.
After credits after credits.
After.
Credits after credits after credits.
After after credits.
First milkman, then sailor man, now Santa.
Post after outro credits.
Post post credits.
Oh my god, Arthur Lee came up with this script.
Arthur.
Arthur like, oh my god.
Arthur did so much in this game.
What the hell?
Don't push start till Christmas.
It's...
Outer saving.
Tree top glistens.
Sentries listen.
Happy sneaking war is covert.
The very next day you gave my position away.
He sees you when you're sneaking.
Whoops, that's me.
You feed on some eggnog.
A clutter on the lawn.
I count some swans and you're gone.
This not snake eater is so great.
Eggnog drinker.
Oh, Mr. Claus.
Why must you leave?
I'll be lonely until Christmas Eve.
Until Christmas Eve.
Merry Gear Solid 2.
I like how the L is still in the four shape.
Ghost of Christmas Past.
So what happened?
I don't know.
It seems like I might have inhaled a bit too much of that sleeping gas.
I can't remember a thing after I wished you a Merry Christmas.
Hmm, yeah, your codec call got out there too.
So, sleeping gas.
Why assume you've gotten into the Merry Gear?
I don't think so.
Why not?
Because when I woke up, the Merry Gear was gone.
Well, at least we've got Tragic Tim.
We can interrogate him once he wakes up.
If he wakes up.
Yes, it all went according to plan.
Yes, they all entered their passcodes.
But the Merry Gear is safely out of their hands.
It was as easy as hiding a package in the mission files.
They thought it was sleeping gas.
Yeah, the poison gas was quite effective.
Poison gas?
Forgetting serum.
Forgetting serum?
He won't remember that we'd even met.
Oh my god.
He had no idea.
I'm convinced he'd believe anything after all that double and triple crossing.
The corroborating information we learned from playing Merry Gear Solid Secret Santa only convinced him further.
With the VR training, my voice...
nearly indistinguishable from the original.
The bloodlines of the three wise men are cut, and the Merry Gear is ours.
Not a single person can get in our way.
If only the three wise men had been more complicit.
Not a single one of them entered their passcode when they had the chance.
Yes, the Hi-Ho-Ho-Ho shall rise again.
Problems?
I assumed it was just a matter of...
Bach!
Hamburg!
Then put the warheads in the boxes and learn some poop!
Scrooge?
Oh my gosh, we have to get Scrooge and we have to get the Grinch and we have to get...
Oh my god, the Hi-He-Ho-Ho...
Wait, the Hi-He-Ho-Ho-Ho really got me good.
Can't believe I'm an elephant in this game too.
Thanks for playing what was my unconventional introduction to Metal Gear so long ago.
For anyone who's curious, the dev is currently working on a game called Sun Kiss City.
A more urban take on Stardew Valley.
Which he also worked on.
Yo!
No way!
This twist is hurting my smooth boyin'.
Solid as Scrooge.
Enemies in love, Zero.
Oh my gosh, no!
I didn't get any!
I have nobody to love this Christmas.
Is there a Merry Gear 3?
There is not.
This was so great!
Oh my god, the twist!
Literally, me.
Me.
That was so good!
Oh my gosh.
So good.
Same, TBH.
This is a heck of a fan game.
You can tell they love the original Metal Gear so much.
And the other references were great too.
So good.
This is the most minto game you could ever play on Christmas.
Thank you for the stream.
Thank you!
By the way, there is a YouTube teaser showing a 3D Metal Gear Solid 3.
Oh, sorry, Merry Gear Solid 3.
With interesting ideas, but that didn't get made, so...
Up to you if you want to watch it.
How long ago is it from?
Thanks for getting through the game.
Sorry about all the backtracking.
No, it's okay!
Merry Christmas.
Thank you so much, Mr. Podunkian.
Is that how you say it?
Thank you for watching.
I had so much fun.
Wow.
Shame we'll never get a third game.
We need more games like the classic Metal Gear games.
Tiny Metal was a little too hammy for my...
I don't know Tiny Metal.
Do you know any other games like this?
Have you played Unmetal?
Unmetal?
Unmetal is also...
You know.
There were some things in Unmetal that I obviously had criticism about.
But overall I think it was a lot of fun.
What was actually in the zip file?
Oh yeah, let me see.
It says sleepgrenade.txt
That's what was in package.zip Was sleepgrenade.txt Wait, let me see if I open it.
What does it say?
Sleepgrenade.
That's all it says.
So good.
So much fun.
That's so awesome.
Oh my gosh, that's so awesome.
I also noticed there was a soft restart.
Maybe I should have done that when it was...
Oh, I see!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh.
I literally see you, Arthur.
In the readme.
I see your gmail.
Super nostalgic.
Played these when I was a kid.
No way!
That was so much fun.
Thank you guys for watching.
And I hope this was a good way to...
A good...
Silly way...
To have the Christmas cheer.
And be all festive.
That was so much fun.
That was so much fun!
I'm super duper hungry.
I didn't have dinner yet, so...
I'm really, really hungry.
So I think I'm gonna hop off here.
But I'm glad you guys enjoyed.
Ding!
Fries are done!
Yeah, thank you guys!
I have another stream tomorrow.
And then I'll be gone for a week and a half.
In Japan.
I don't plan to stream while I'm over there.
Maybe do like a...
Twitter space or something for New Year's, but...
I don't plan on bringing my computer.
Since it's a bit of a hassle.
And I would only want to stream for New Year's, I think.
But I don't really want to bring my whole laptop and all my stuff.
Just for one stream.
I hope you guys understand.
Self-deserve!
Thank you for the super chat!
Merry Christmas, Merry Christmas!
So...
It's like so heavy and it's so much stuff that I have to put in my carry-on.
Because I can't put it in my suitcase.
And so it's like...
It's like such a hassle.
Minto's taking an actual real vacation.
Let's go.
Stop it!
Why are you cheering that?
Won't you miss me?
You're not gonna miss me?
Merry Christmas, Minto.
Wishing you and the Wisps a lovely day.
Whether you celebrate or not, I hope you all treat yourselves to wonderful things today.
Thanks, Tri Princess!
Of course we will.
Maybe a little.
My heart won't be able to take it.
But we still have tomorrow, so...
No worries.
Otsumita!
Thank you for the funny Christmas stream.
Enjoy your trip.
Thank you!
Minto's taking an actual real vacation.
Let's go.
We'll miss you.
Have a great vacation, Minto.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
But things are only going to ramp up next year, so...
Brighton!
Welcome back!
Thank you for the off-stream.
Don't know, I saw it.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Really appreciate it.
We'll miss you, but you deserve the vacation.
I don't even deserve it that much.
You guys, all I do is stream.
It's fine.
I really don't.
I feel bad.
I stream.
I have the easiest job ever.
It's fine.
Personal time is important too.
Well, I have lots of stories to talk about, hopefully.
I'll go to many maid cafes and I'll tell you guys lots of stuff about Comiket and everything and everything.
But like I said, we still have tomorrow, so we'll get to talk lots and lots tomorrow instead.
So stop acting like I'm leaving tonight, okay?
Otsumito, everybody!
Merry Christmas!
I hope you guys had lots of fun today.
Hopefully you guys got to enjoy lots of all the Christmas activities that people have been streaming all over.
And hopefully, if you didn't spend it with family, you got to spend it with friends.
Or you got to spend it with us, which is still awesome.
And you got to at least rest, hopefully.
Hopefully you didn't have to work.
And if you did have to work, please get some rest.
Otsumito!
I spent it with Vtubers.
That's why I try to stream on holidays.
Because I know not everybody can be with somebody.
So you can be here.
You're with us.
You're hanging out.
We're all hanging out.
I miss Mint.
I'm right here.
Otsumito, get some rest.
Get some good food.
And I'll see you guys tomorrow.
Or when I see you, see you next.
Bye bye!
My stream deck is not working.
What's happening?
Everything is breaking.
OK, bye.